[تصفيق]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم في تصعيد متواصل بالضفه
الغربيه الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقتل مواطنا
فلسطينيا اصابته في راسه خلال اقتحامها
قريه عقابه بطوباس اذاعه الجيش تقر بفشل
عمليه اعتقال احد المقاومين بعد اشتباكات
وكتيبه سرايا القدس تجدد التزامها بالتصدر
الاحتلال مهما ارتفعت الكلفه
تزامنا مع هجمات بالمسيرات على الداخل
الروسي كيف تختبروا بنجاح صاروخا باليسيا
مداه 700 كيلومتر وعمده موسكو يطالب
بتعزيز الدفاعات في العاصمه هذا وتضع
روسيا نظام الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه سارمات
في الخدمه القتاليه
استطلاع راي في السويد يكشف ان نسبه
المواطنين الذين يؤيدون فرض حظر على حرق
نسخ من المصحف الشريف وغيره من الكتب
المقدسه ارتفعت الى 53% في المقابل ايد
37% حرق الكتب المقدسه ضمن نطاق حريه
التعبير بينما لم يبدل الباقون رايا محددا
مهاجم نادي مانشستر سيتي ايرلينج هالاند
يحظى بجائزه افضل لاعب في اوروبا بعد ان
ساهم بفوز فريقه بلقب دوري الابطال موسم
الماضي وما يعرف بالثلاثيه هذا وتم اختيار
الاسباني
كافضل مدرب في القاره وتوجت ايتانا
بونماتي لاعبه برشلونه بجائزه افضل لاعبه
بعد فوزها مع المنتخب بمونديال السيدات
الى اللقاء